tetralogy of fellow is a birth defect
that changes normal blood flow through a
baby's heart
a healthy heart has four chambers the
right atrium and right ventricle and the
left atrium and left ventricle
after delivering oxygen to the body
oxygen poor blood flows into the right
atrium
when the right atrium contracts it loads
blood into the relaxed right ventricle
then the right ventricle contracts
sending blood to the lungs through the
pulmonary artery
the blood picks up oxygen in the lungs
then returns to the left atrium
the left atrium contracts filling the
relaxed left ventricle with blood
and the left ventricle contracts to pump
and deliver oxygen-rich blood to the
body through the aorta
tetralogy of fellow is a birth defect
made up of four problems with the heart
and its blood vessels
a ventricular septal defect or vsd is a
hole in the wall between the two
ventricles
the hole allows oxygen-rich blood to mix
with oxygen poor blood
an overriding aorta means the aorta is
shifted slightly from its usual location
on the heart
it sits right over the ventricular
septal defect
this allows blood from both ventricles
to flow through the aorta
as a result some oxygen poor blood may
flow to the body
pulmonary stenosis means that the main
pulmonary artery is narrowed
and the pulmonary valve doesn't open all
the way
as a result of the narrowing less blood
reaches the lungs
right ventricular hypertrophy means the
wall of the right ventricle is thicker
than normal
this is thought to happen in response to
blood flow through the ventricular
septal defect
and from having to work harder to pump
blood through the narrowed pulmonary
artery which results in increased blood
pressure
together these four problems may prevent
enough oxygen from reaching the baby's
body
this may result in episodes of a
condition called cyanosis or blue baby
in this condition the baby's skin lips
and fingernails may have a bluish tint
to find out more about tetralogy of
fellow talk to your healthcare provider
you